[Musique]
on a une société spécialisée sur le
sujet de la mobilité mais dans l'espace
donc en fait tous les objets les
satellites donc déjà il y en a de plus
en plus dans l'espace pour répondre à
des besoins terrestres de connectivité
d'observation de la Terre d'exploration
au sens large et en fait tous ces objets
au-delà de leur mouvement naturel autour
de la Terre il va falloir les bouger
tout au long de leur vie d'abord en
début de vie pour rejoindre les orbites
sur lequel ils vont fonctionner ensuite
les maintenir sur l'orbite et puis en
fin de vie de plus en plus il va falloir
faire quelque chose de ces objets soit
les mettre sur des orbites parking soit
les faire redescendre pour pouvoir
éviter en fait de polluer l'espace et en
fait tout ça c'est de la mobilité et exo
trail ce spécialise sur l'organisation
de cette mobilité et ça c'est la
définition de la logistique donc
exotrail c'est une société de logistique
spatiale
on est un pur produit de Paris-Saclay
parce qu'en fait on a démarré sur le
plateau en 2015 ou en fait on a réuni un
ensemble d'établissements de Paris
Saclay donc l'école politique le CNRS
l'observatoire de Versailles 51 en
Yvelines en particulier l'université de
Versailles 51 en Yvelines le 5 retrans
soleil et en fait on a proposé un projet
à l'organisme de transfert de
technologie de Paris-Saclay la SAT et
c'est à partir de là qu'on a commencé en
fait à travailler sur l'un de nos
premiers produits c'est un propulseur
pour le marché des petits satellites et
donc on a démarré au sein du CNRS avec
tous les établissements que j'ai
mentionnés et de fil en aiguille on a
commencé à obtenir des bons résultats et
la voix de valorisation en fait de ce
projet ça a été la création d'une
entreprise exotrail qu'on a
officiellement créé en 2017
donc après la création d'entreprise on
s'est d'abord installé à l'incubateur à
l'accélérateur de Polytechnique donc le
centre dry et puis en 2018 en fait on
s'installe ici à Massy en même temps on
s'installe à Toulouse ça c'est une
particularité de l'entreprise depuis nos
débuts on est sur les deux sites et j'en
ai aujourd'hui une centaine de personnes
donc à peu près les deux tiers des
effectifs à Massy ici et puis un tiers à
Toulouse et on a du coup progressé très
vite
création du coût de l'entreprise en 2017
sans personne en 2023 et on a une
ambition afin 2023 d'être à peu près 160
personnes
je suis ravi de d'être parrain de cette
promotion 2023 de Spring 50 il y a
plusieurs éléments le premier c'est la
thématique spatiale en particulier qui
est mis qui est mis en valeur il y a
beaucoup de compétences sur le
Paris-Saclay au sens large dans le
domaine spatial il y a un énorme
potentiel créé un pôle spatial de rang
international on a tous les ingrédients
pour ça on a des très bons laboratoires
de recherche des entités de recherche on
a des écoles on a des universités on a
des centres de recherche privées qui se
sont beaucoup installés et puis on a des
startups aujourd'hui comme exo trail on
n'est pas les seuls issus de Paris sacré
il y en a d'autres et au-delà de ça le
potentiel global de Paris-Saclay et bien
au-delà de cette thématique spatiale
cette richesse des domaines de recherche
couverts par Paris-Saclay permet
effectivement aujourd'hui l'émergence de
beaucoup de projets de start-up
issus de Paris-Saclay dans des domaines
complètement différents que ce soit
d'intelligence artificielle de la
robotique
des sciences potentiellement humaines et
sociales etc et donc je suis ravi de
pouvoir démontrer que on peut
issu de Paris sacs faire un projet
entrepreneurial qui aujourd'hui est dans
une phase de croissance
internationalisation et qui est au final
très ambitieux sur une thématique en
particulier qui est spatiale
[Musique]